la terre-sainte à l'épreuve du
coronavirus israël y un palestinien
chaque camp géré la pandémie avec les
moyens dont il dispose ceux de l'état
hébreu sont sans surprise plus important
face à la propagation de l'épidémie les
autorités ont mis en place des drive-in
qui permettent un dépistage plus rapide
selon le dernier recensement
israël compte plus de 2000 cas positifs
nous essayons d'abord de faire
fonctionner le drive in
pour l'instant nous avons fait le
premier essai juste pour que vous voyez
et pour expliquer à tout le monde
comment ça fonctionne un stato que tout
marche bien et nous avons donc commencé
aujourd'hui avec 300 vrais citoyens qui
vont venir ici pour que nous puissions
prélever des échantillons côté
palestinien la situation est plus
incertaine dimanche deux premiers cas
ont été recensés dans la bande de gaza
une enclave complètement coupés du monde
en raison du blocus imposé par israël
un contexte jugé alarmant par l'onu qui
n'hésite pas à évoquer un désastre en
cas de propagation
c'est illusoire de penser qu'on peut
gérer une telle situation dans un espace
clos comme celui ci cela pourrait être
un gigantesque désastre dans l'urgence
la construction d'un hôpital de campagne
a été lancée afin d'accueillir les
patients atteints du virus
situé à rafah au sud de la bande de gaza
il servira également de centre de
quarantaine pour les personnes
concernées
rhodia un centre de quarantaine est en
cours de construction dans deux zones
différentes
une partie se trouvant dans la zone de
rafah qui comprend 600 chambres une
autre près du croisement de beit hanoun
qui comprend 400 chambres mais doit ces
lieux seront équipés et chaque chant
disposera de tous les services
nécessaires comme des toilettes toutes
les personnes revenant de l'étranger
seront logés dans ce centre de
quarantaine
isolement est obligatoire il ne sera pas
possible de se rassembler et la chambre
accueillera au maximum deux personnes
face à cette menace sanitaire d'une
ampleur inédite
des représentants de l'om est se sont
rendus dans ce territoire exigu où
vivent deux millions de personnes